اتوجه بالشكر والحمد لله رب العالمين من
الدرجه الاولى وكما وتوجه بالشكر لقناه
العربيه التي قامت بالبث المباشر ونحن على
اعصابنا وقريبه اعصابنا من الامنيات كما
يتوجه بالشكر الى كل ما قال بمساعدتنا
بهذه الرحله واقاده وحكومه ومسؤولين ورجال
امن وفرق دفاع مدني وفرق بين
كل من اعطى وما بمساعدتنا وكان يتابعنا
لحظه بلحظه والى كل ما قام بالدعاء لنا في
كل انحاء العالم واطلب منهم الدعاء ان
يكون ان يكون الله عونا لنا على حسن
تربيتهم بما يرضي الله في باقي ايام كيف
هي صحه فاطمه وعائشه وهل تمكنت من
الاطمئنان على عائشه عفوا فاطمه وخديجه
تكلمت مع فاطمه وخديجه وهم بصحه كامله
وجيده
كانهم يعني كانهم لم يكن هناك اي شيء ولكن
جزاهم الله خيرا
بالعنايه المشدده لاستمرار
عليهم وان
يتابعوا حالتهم بشكل الكامل ووضعهم ممتاز
جدا جدا جدا
عائشه لا اعلم اي شيء حاليا انا اتابعكم
على على القناه وبعدها سوف اتكلم مع
اولادي في متابعتهم بالمشافي الحمد لله
على سلامتها سيد اشرف شكرا لانضمامك لنا
ونتمنى لكم وللجميع السلامه طبعا
اكرر وانا اكرر جزيل الشكر لكم على هذه
المتابعه وعلى هذه حسن
النيه وحسن المتابعه